have you ruined your chances of becoming
Prime Minister mr. Johnson mr. Johnson
while police outside your house last
night questions that need answering but
mr. Johnson refusing to oblige begin in
the final stages of his bid to be p.m.
under the cloud of newspaper headlines
about a domestic incident at his
girlfriend's flat there is one subject
on everybody's lips today and they want
to know why the police were called to
your house in the early hours of Friday
morning I don't think they want to hear
about that kind of thing just taking up
a minute with that answer which has told
us absolutely nothing does a person's
private life have any bearing on their
ability to discharge the office of Prime
Minister but so just to be clear you're
not going to make any comment at all on
what happened lost I think that's pretty
that's pretty obvious from the foregoing
[Applause]
the room sympathetic on this one not so
much on other policy and character
questions in June last year during a
Foreign Office reception you were asked
about corporate concerns regarding a
hard brexit you replied business is your
attitude towards British jobs still as
Cavalier and as careless as it obviously
was to them I'm the most passionately
pro-business conservative politician you
could hope to me and I you know I I've
never I've never known one single stray
distorted remark wrenched out of context
a political rock star for sure but the
quieter continuity candidate Jeremy Hunt
also trying to show he has the
personality and policy to lead they're
running a campaign to help me find the
slogan that I should be putting to the
country into the membership and we've
had hash tag take a punt on hunt hash
tag jezus the bezu and hash tag hunt
amok hunts face I'll be very very
careful how you say that one because we
are the power
- you have family values but he has to
battle the perception that he isn't a
true brexit believer why should they
support someone who didn't vote leave
and just doesn't feel it in your gut the
same way that they do oh yes I do
look at my record look at my records
since that referendum I have been very
clear on every occasion that we needed
to fight hard to get the best possible
deal from the European Union and I have
voted for braixen the Foreign Secretary
true to his word that he wants a clean
fight I'm not going to talk about his
private life but I do think he should
stand on a stage and debate me before
members get their balance in the post
because you know we need a proper debate
the clear underdog his only hopes to win
over the heads if not the hearts I came
in quite sure I was going to be Pro
Boris right I thought we had that kind
of dichotomy between Boris being the
kind of cult of personality and he you
know it was obviously very well received
very funny but then Jeremy seemed a lot
more hot in the detail and a lot more
policy-driven
I kind of think that Boris would
probably do more hurt in the country in
lots of different ways most here agree
with Boris Johnson when it comes to his
private life but this was a warm rather
than ecstatic reception for mr. Johnson
today Mr Hunt started this run off as an
also-ran he'll leave Birmingham with
more of a spring in his step
bethe Rigby Sky News Birmingham